I think it's okay that there are things
you can't describe in life I think
that's
okay it was a Nutty night it was my
first picture I was glad to have a
ticket it was a Thrill Ride all of a
sudden it you know we'd been marching
through the mud for so long my
self-identity as a writer and that came
first our winner is James Brooks for
Terms of
Endearment once writing happened my life
was good and so everything else was
truly surreal it's always very hard to
get a finishing moment with a picture
and winning for writing was a was a good
clean yippy it's finished and then I got
it for directing the winner is James L
Brooks the terms of
endearment it looked like somebody had
been shoted my body recoiled and and I
always had this theory that if you say
something inappropriate enough nobody
will realize you said it cuz it's too
far outside of making any sense at all I
feel like I've been beaten up it's
strange I I have no explanation for that
but there it was that's how it felt I
was having a good time I was happy you
know and uh and then I was a lot happier
the winner is Terms of
Endearment directing a picture writing a
picture are two different kinds of legal
Insanity I think I mean you know each
experience that depends on you going
nuts in a certain way and it wears
people down and it didn't wear the
people around me down and I think that
you got to think of those people when
the picture wins because the picture the
picture is everybody worked on it and
and some this is an extraordinary
evening for us there's no way to express
the Gratitude thank you very
[Music]
much